braquage il a bien sa carrière dans quel
état vous êtes sabah tout le monde a
bien j'avais prévu quoi pour les
vacances d'ailleurs tiens castaldi bah
écoutez pas grand chose en fait quoi
passer ça va être long et vacances à
vous avez prévu quoi papa droit je vous
dit pas grand chose vous dire
honnêtement pour l'instant pas
grand-chose l'instant rien toujours avec
votre salma se décomposera avec votre
femme
ah oui toujours faisais ma femme j'aime
d'amour d'accord ça va mieux je sais pas
mais non parce que généralement je crois
que ce thème mais c'était pas comme
l'annonçait toujours foutent le bordel
dans ma vie est ce que j'en dirais je
pense est pas fou j'ai confondu avec qui
j'ai convenu que nico qui est devenu
célibataire voilà c'est ça ça doit vous
devez faire quoi cet été mais
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas encore je me
suis très sérieux c'est faire quoi set
mais je vais je ne faisais pas je crois
je vais un peu chez genton ouais ouais
et démontage excusez moi tout le monde
bachelot de givet le 1er juillet et
delphine m'a dit qu'elle venait aussi
oui c'est vrai je possède avant les
dates de delphine mollet gauche
[Rires]
je vous cache pas que je m'en fous roger
dacquois roger legris combien elle un mi
juillet sans roger mi juillet sans
région roger en sera mi août
sans roger est bien mi juillet sont là
là là un vrai délire est-ce que vous
avez prévenu la maire de saint phalle
base comme les tailles d'essence alors
parler puisque vous savez que la maman
de samuel base afin c'est le fit avec
des ouvres ton et apparemment ils
commencent à ce qui fait la vaisselle et
bien savoir ace team wespiser vient chez
vous bien je lui ai jamais quoi il ya
une semaine tout seul oui sur ces
négociations a pour l'instant c'est avec
mais je pense qu'avec son effet
pigeonner voile a été levé pigeons à cet
atelier à bien sans mais il ya toujours
rougis québec ne pas céder à l armée
rouge il est toujours un les jeunes
oui ça c'est ça ouais isa géraldine et
moi n'a pas qualité bah je suis un petit
peu normal je viens chez vous si de
trois jours je crois ah oui avec michel
drucker
ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai je les invitais à m'habiter
invité michel drucker
c'est en tout cas le délai ni toi ô
posez vous les bonnes questions de
carrière
[Applaudissements]
les invités on ne va jamais castaldi
michel drucker moyens petit pelé
qu'ailleurs voiture que burnout et là tu
te dis oui je peux venir c'est vous moi
je cherche un hébergement c'est mieux
franchement oui je préfère vous dire non
tout ça on doit vous n'ayez pas d'espoir
pendant les vacances
qu'est ce que vous allez faire ou cet
été les ja déjà je pense qu'il faut
passer au un bon mois chez le coiffeur
[Rires]
pour moi c'est le fort quoi obligatoires
demain matin doit vous avez fait pas
peur quand vous allez faire quoi
un petite innovation capillaires pour
vous plaire oh là là voilà pourquoi nous
venons prix j'aimerais avoir les photos
demande à quoi donc demain soir il est
arrivé avec une nouvelle couprie
d'accord alors si on veut y faire quoi
pendant les vacances que je vais aller à
la rochelle je verrai à nîmes
oui et je vais peut-être aller avec
fatto quelques jours en italie
c'est bien ça vous en foutez oui
complètement
[Applaudissements]
eelv à la rochelle
ouais après je sais y va après en italie
je crois même fatouma la maman car le
cucquois beinheim et moi j'ai fait un
saut au dessus de la france ça ne
m'allait pas clair si je demandais ce
que j'allais faire pour les vacances à
dire est que je demandais c'est parti
c'est pas encore tout caler mais je vous
dis les résidents en france si je vais
dans le sud dans le sud où ça mais du
côté d'antibes savez j'adore côté de
chez swann voilà ces 14 et avec patoche
et bien sûr ils demandent toujours
regarder salle vacances en perspective
il va faire quoi
alors je l'habille hot une quinzaine de
jours les attendent à côté bien sûr que
vous allez à biot
c'est un centre de tennis et un très
grand sens de la nature a long way c'est
là-bas que vous avez entraîné nasri mais
c'est là-bas que vous allez vous
attendez attendez pas ce que je vous dis
il ya un très bon centre de tenir bien
sûr c'est mon centre d'entraînement je
vous serai là-bas aussi
je serai là bas il le sait je ne sais
pas du tout non
j'ai des amis avaient autant je serai
tous les joueurs d'écorcher mois tulu
d'accord première année vous entraîner
avec grand plaisir
[Rires]
en espagne comment d'accord c'est des
amis qui sont qui ont les reins solides
ouais parce que pour avoir dépressif à
la maison
ça va le moral ils vont m'aider à m'en
sortir là ils ont le moral parce que je
voulais à répondre et à pas dépressif
tous les matins il ya plus de bonnes
coup ce sont les biscayens pulby scotia
pur biscotte
vous êtes tout seul avec le couple pas
du tout on est une bonne bande de
copains
vous nous direz la raison sur les frais
en passant elle avait charrié qu'est-ce
que ça ne sert à rien c'est un stade
moga donner un truc au cadeau de ma
tenue le 6 fano nîmes
d'accord on se rencontre une fois tous
les trois mois bas côté mais on choisit
toujours des combats ont cessé dans
cette maison une dizaine une dizaine
pour rentrer radu noir scène ils sont
par tradition venir approche très ferme
moi c'est dans le serrait les dents
c'est pourquoi nous ne t'aimons
[Applaudissements]
mais en étant plus ou m'énerver là parce
que tout à l'heure je suis en train de
vous dire bat wc guillaume je pars en
vacances et tout est là qu'est ce que
vous répondez oui à delphine wespiser
qui va là bas
actuellement c'est vexant reste des
élections faisait quoi il vaut mieux
être vexant ephron qu'hypocrite et
malhonnête
non je crois je préfère le vert content
que vous alliez dans le sud
alors d'abord je vais à marseille comme
un concert avec m radio avec amir sayoud
sans s'emballer ensuite marcell jansen
chez guillaume et ce sera son
anniversaire
non j'ai un peu l'angoissé parce que je
vous le savez il aime que les vêtements
de marque
ouais donc rien pour sanctionner quand
quelqu'un vous n'écoutez pas je voulais
dit le 1er le 2 juillet 1er et 2 juin
vous êtes si guillaume genton à la
tension niveau alors qu'est ce tu fais
quoi moi je parle de carreaux un peu car
on sait la mère de sacha
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des amis j'ai été malade ou quelques
jours tranquilles à carreaux apprenait
dans le sud fait quelques jours avec
caro tranquille après on va dans le sud
avec des amis je lui ai présenté mes
amis ah ouais je serai là bah oui bien
sûr mais quand vous voulez et vous at il
fallu bons voisins ouais ouais moi
d'aller au bout en sicile dans la
famille de mon compagnon
ah ouais allez on aura la cub nhtsa ah
non pourquoi c'est génial je suis entré
les sensations étaient allés dans la
famille de souleymane m'baye après usher
peuvent être si l'on va me faire chier à
mourir
vous devriez venir vous adorerez la ccja
ouais bon et les deux je m'en fous je
rigole isabelle moi je vais faire du
badminton et bien allez pas posé la
question
vous avez entendu des vacances de tous
les chroniqueurs ça nous met un coup
dans la gueule sans rigoler est-ce
qu'ils sont pas mieux sur le plateau
sans faille et que des vacances de merde
y'a que des vacances report les oui on
est dans une maison ou un biotope
pénétrèrent et déjà rien que non bios
baba est sérieux on leur dit résorber
qui suit à faire là-bas à biot mes
frères je te jure avec des amis moi j'ai
pas besoin de grand chose puisque mes
amis me suffisent ouais mais vois toi tu
fais pas tes amis des amis qui sont dans
le jeu un petit peu chez io motion
jamais mario alors invité
[Rires]
les téléspectateurs je remarque un petit
truc moi c'est que guillaume genton n'a
invité que les meufs et m'a fait mal à
tous ceux qui ont la poitrine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les deux maires des cinq ans et venait
apparemment non non non je vois ce venin
mais sérieux et non mais voilà ça aurait
un vrai que tous en topless autour de la
piscine
merci jeu c'est une horreur castany se
pavaner au topless dans votre ville à
ses membres un ça va non mais
franchement un ça va vous vous allez
faire quoi c'était c'est quoi si au
niveau des syriens c'est un mec c'est
fait alors maintenant quand un mec ça
prends tu dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'appartiens va partir c'est sûr et
certain de sa acer a été on va reparler
bien entendu je vais me faire inviter un
peu partout alors ça y est ma j'ai 2 3
alors vous êtes ça ils vous ont mis
définitivement dans le public de
l'émission où elles s'exercent à des
copains j'ai quelques amis dans des
maisons tout ça je vais je trouver une
petite ouverture d'accord pourquoi vous
êtes avec nous ce soir mon téléphone a
sonné à mai à midi comme tous les jours
vous je vous dire que je vous entends
oui je vous vois et moi ou non que je
pense que votre place est à biot que
possible merci contre lorsqu'on peut par
contre pour les vacances parce qu'on
peut pas faire pour toi pour les
vacataires pour moi ouais si excitant
puisque nous c'est alors moi mais ça
veut dire lundi autorise boyard et je te
le dis je j'ai pris tous mes tournois de
paddle qui se passe en france entière
avait déjà fait mon coéquipier thomas
que tu connais qui est en train de tout
préparer
et donc là on va faire picton à de
paddle partout en france wendy pas là et
bien je vous signale oui mais samba
c'est pas mal
c'est bon on fait des tournois n'ont pas
seniors ouvert à tous c'est quoi
l'objectif de classement l'an enfin les
300 premiers et on viendrait ici en
septembre vous serez dans les 300
premiers à mon sens c'est un monstre
non mais je ne suis pas tous nuls alors
je voulais témoigner pour commencer
cette année 300 français aux mondiaux
madail 300 français parce que vous avez
un melon vous pour le jeu la côte on
nettoie un melon à melon avec les utah
c'est juste une soeur
[Rires]